now we would like to introduce a trio of
stars ladies and gentlemen not one not
two but three a trio of stars who
actually need no introduction but I just
wanted to fatten my part a little to
present the Writing Awards from England
dick vogue Dirk Bogarde I'm sorry from
America Van Heflin and from a Hot Tin
Roof miss Elizabeth Taylor
nominated for the Best Screenplay based
on material from another medium our Cat
on a Hot Tin Roof screenplay by Richard
Brooks and James Polk GG screenplay by
alan jay lerner the horse's mouth
screenplay by Alec Guinness I want to
live screenplay by Nelson getting and
dong-man woods separate table screenplay
by Terence Rattigan
and John Gay and the winner is alan jay
lerner
just thank you very much denominations
for the best Orion screenplay written
directly for the screen are the Defiant
ones story and screenplay by Nathan e
Douglas and Harold Jacob small the
goddess story in screenplay by Paddy
Chayefsky houseboat story and screenplay
by Mel
Melville Sheldon and Jack Rose the sheep
man story by James Edward grant
screenplay by william Bowers and James
Edward grant teacher the winner is the
defiant
thank you very much
very gratifying and very exciting thank
you